with news that we're going to be getting
a Stargate movie from MGM I asked you
guys a simple question
what film do you want to see
and the answer was very interesting
welcome to Star Trek your Sci-Fi TV the
movie channel
[Music]
so I put a question on the Community
page what Stargate movie do you want MGM
to make we have to start somewhere so if
it was strongly related to a series
which series do you think wouldn't be
most exciting to see hard reboot is of
course a different way to go and was one
of the options
so option one sg1 should this be an sg1
Revival heavily related to the daddy of
the series the series that started it
all or should it be related to Stargate
Atlantis maybe return to the Atlantis
maybe we go off and Fight The Wraith
again or should it be related to
Stargate Universe we've heard rumors
that Robert Carlisle has been approached
and maybe even David blue or should it
be anything as long as it's not a hard
reboot for the love of God don't do a
hard reboot well we have the results now
this vote was quite popular we got one
and a half thousand votes and out of one
of a half thousand votes SG-1 got 21
percent
Stargate Atlantis Revival got 10 percent
a hard reboot got seven percent of the
votes and oh my God anything as long as
it's not a hard reboot got 26 of the
votes
but you might notice I quietly left one
out there
Stargate Universe
because that got 36 percent of the votes
so a quarter of you out there 26 percent
don't care what the movie's about as
long as it's Target and as long as it's
not a hard reboot seven percent of you
out there actually want a hard reboot
and even though I don't I can't
understand where you're coming from
Stargate got so powerful in the town we
got so powerful towards the end of sg1
that a hard reboot after 20 years might
make sense because in the end of the day
we want a Stargate series we don't want
to just Star Trek with a different coat
on
sg1 got 21 of the votes that's pretty
good because that's apparently what
we're actually going to be getting if
the rumors that we're hearing out of MGM
are to be believed
10 is a bit disappointing for SGA now I
love Stargate Atlantis but to be fair I
can kind of see why it even though I
might want to see the Atlantis I might
want to see some of those characters
again
I don't necessarily want a series based
around it or a movie based around it so
10 of the vote for that okay I
understand
Stargate Universe though
over a third of you want that
over a third of you have all of the
options want a Stargate Universe movie
to kick off the franchise and now I know
what movie you want because many of you
have told me repeatedly in comments when
we've talked about Stargate Universe in
the past you want a continuation and a
conclusion to the Stargate Universe
mystery you want Eli and rush and
Telford and everyone you want them all
to come home
you want them to find out what the
mysterious signal was you want them to
find out who the planet Builders were
you want all of the answers to these
Mysteries that were so cruelly taken
away from us with the cancellation of
season two to finally get answered but
could that possibly work
well look from a Gator's point of view
Stargate Universe was always a Marmite
kind of show people loved or hated it as
you know I've said more than once I
found the series a little boring I
thought it started brilliantly I thought
it ran it just got dull towards the end
of season one season two didn't start
great but it got better it was getting
better and I was really loving it by the
end but
for me Atlantis was just as good really
at Parts as sg1 but sg1 is the daddy sg1
reinvented itself several times it's
just a better show it was about formula
for the show it had some fun to it it
had all of that SGU lacked that fun it
lacked that you know sense of humor it
took itself a little bit too seriously
for me
but the people that love Stargate
Universe are desperate to have that
conclusion and
it's big questions this Target Universe
asked this signal that was hidden within
the background radiation of the universe
that's not a little thing I mean if you
think about sci-fi shows a lot of sci-fi
shows can be seriously ambitious you
know they can have a big problems that
are trying to be solved but a signal
hidden in the background radiation of
the universe
that's ambitious
I mean that meant that that would have
had to have been hidden within the
background radiation at the point or
near after the point of the Big Bang
13.6 billion years ago whatever it was
so that is a species that existed before
time
before our universe
now they talked a lot about God and
spirituality accepted Etc in Stargate
Universe they talked about this being
the God's message
now even Rush didn't mean that literally
maybe in the way Catholics Etc would
consider the word god with a big G but
if you think about the storyline and the
general idea of Stargate from beginning
to end this idea about false gods this
idea about actually these gods that we
have revered our entire you know Society
are actually just Advanced aliens and
that there is a logical explanation for
all of these things that we see
was SGU going to be just a natural
evolution of that original idea and that
they were going to get a false god that
is actually as close to being God as
it's possible to imagine now don't get
me wrong the Ancients were already
Godlike after they ascended they behaved
in god-like ways but they were just
beings of energy they were still
actually ascended from corporeal beings
like us
what on Earth could have been so
powerful that one it existed at the
start of the big bang and two was able
to create that message in the first
place with the ascended with the planet
Builders with other species that we got
to see at times within the Stargate
Universe where those lines were blurred
between that of alien and God
could Stargate of the universe gone even
further and answered some of those
biggest questions
why are we here
what was here before
and what is the point of it all so a
Stargate Universe movie has got some
pretty big questions to answer it's
going to have to be bloody clever and we
have to assume that Joseph malozi Brad
right Etc did have answers to these
questions when they you know started the
series and a movie could actually
kick-start this franchise in a massive
way if they had a clever way to answer
those questions but
Stargate Universe even though it is
absolutely loved by the Gators that love
the show
it was canceled because it was not
watched enough
it never quite captured the imagination
of a lot of gators
it is a show that out of the three is
what's the least and really had the
least impact
so why would you return with SGU if
you're an executive in charge of Amazon
what would the reason be
well if you want a movie that's going to
please 30 percent of the people that
voted today
then the SGU movie is the way to go
but think about it like this way as well
SGU ended the franchise
wouldn't it be nice to restart the
franchise
where we left off
maybe but guys get to the comments tell
me what you think does a Stargate
Universe movie make sense if it does
what sort of movie would you like to see
what sort of storyline would you like to
see we've got some very imaginative
people out there
give me some of those ideas I'd love to
know we're actually going to be doing a
live video next weekend or we're going
to give our ideas about what a Stargate
Universe movie could look like and I'd
love you guys to join us for it
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you will never miss any of our new
videos also go over to our sister
Channel sites where I do a weekly
Stargate update video which Gators do
not want to miss all the links in the
description finally you can go to
patreon.com forward slash Sidetrack
where you get to see most of our videos
before everybody else for a small
contribution that supports the channel
each month you get to see them before
everybody else on YouTube and without
the adverts I also throw a few little
extra videos on there just for the
patreons
as always guys please stay safe and I'll
see you next time
foreign